The Pass That Allows People to Fly for Free
Forever
Back in 1981, in an effort to raise some quick
funds, American Airlines introduced a $250,000
pass (about $641,000 today) that would allow
customers to fly on its airlines for free
for the rest of their lives.
In 1990, they bumped the price to $600,000
(about $1.07 million today), and then in 1993
to $1.01 million (about 1.7 million today).
Despite the sticker price, the airline has
since admitted this is one of the costliest
mistakes it has ever made.
Introduced in the summer of 1981, the unlimited
“AAirpass” was originally envisioned as,
to quote the airline’s former chief executive
Robert Crandalll, something that “firms
would buy for top employees” and it was
thought that the scheme would bring in many
millions of dollars in revenue in a very short
timespan- essentially, easy money now to grow
the company with, with future costs of having
people use these passes being negligible to
absorb.
However, the AAirpass’ high cost resulted
in a less than enthusiastic response from
customers and in the end, only 66 passes were
actually sold.
This is a shame for consumers, because those
66 customers got an amazing deal.
As Crandall later noted, “It soon became
apparent that the public was smarter than
we were.”
According to the rather loose terms of the
original AAirpass contract, customers who
purchased one were entitled to free first
class travel anywhere in the world and were
given lifetime membership to American Airline’s
Admirals Club, which grants priority boarding,
same day booking and access to lounges across
the world that offer free food and drink for
members.
These benefits alone have seen some likening
the unlimited AAirpass to “owning a fleet
of private planes”.
As one of the top frequent fliers, Steve Rothstein
said, “A very fun Saturday would be to wake
up early and fly to Detroit, rent a car and
go to Ontario, have lunch and spend $50 or
$100 buying Canadian things…” and then
be back by dinner.
In another case, an individual travelled all
the way to London 16 times in a single month,
sometimes just staying long enough for a bite
to eat before flying back home.
But it didn’t stop there.
Savvy customers found ways to get even more
out of their passes.
You see, under the terms of the agreement,
customers were still allowed to claim air
miles on all flights they took, allowing those
who used the service frequently (because why
wouldn’t you?) to rack up literally millions
of air miles in the space of just a handful
of years, which they could give away to family
and friends or in the cases of some customers,
sell.
On top of this, because the AAirpass offered
unlimited free travel, the airline were forced
to absorb any and all fees customers incurred
while using them (including taxes), meaning
customers could literally book a dozen flights
at a dozen different times for a single day
and roll up to their airport whenever they
felt like it, knowing that there would be
no cancellation fees to pay for missing the
other flights or additional duties or taxes
to pay.
But we’re not done yet.
On top of all this, American Airlines offered
customers a chance to purchase a “companion
pass” at a discount price (about 40% off),
which granted all the same perks to anyone
the original holder wanted as long as they
flew together.
Customers who opted for this particular upgrade
utilised it in a number of impressively creative
ways from booking an empty seat under a false
name to score more elbow room in the already
spacious first class, to ferrying friends
and often random strangers across the world
for free.
In the case of a guy called Steven Rothstein,
he’d sometimes book two tickets for every
flight he took just to surprise people at
the airport with a free first class upgrade.
If you’re wondering how customers came up
with all these ideas for bending the rules,
many of them didn’t.
A lot of the aforementioned tricks like booking
multiple flights on a given day or an empty
seat were often suggested to customers by
people working for the airline itself as part
of the complimentary booking service provided
to Admirals Club members.
According to an internal report from American
Airlines in 2007, the top unlimited AAirpass
holders cost the airline in excess of a million
dollars that year, each.
Although, it would be interesting to actually
see how they tallied this up, because if first
class wasn’t sold out on a particular flight
an AAirpass owner took, the airline wouldn’t
actually lose money other than taxes, the
price of in-flight consumables and the like,
as it’s likely many of these customers wouldn’t
have taken the flights in question had they
not had the unlimited pass.
Regardless, the results of this internal report
were alarming enough that it prompted American
Airlines to sic its so-called revenue integrity
unit onto owners of the passes in attempts
to find something they’d done that constituted
a breach of the AAirpass’ terms.
After poring over the contracts and doing
extensive investigations, American Airlines
were able to successfully revoke the passes
of a handful of the customers who’d “abused”
the system the most.
For instance, American tried to coerce certain
people who’d been given a free ride courtesy
of some of the more generous AAirpass owners
into admitting that they’d paid for their
tickets.
In one such case, it was noted in an internal
email from American Airlines that the individual
in question who’d been given a ticket by
AAirpass owner Jacques Vroom, “appears to
be naive, without financial wherewithal, and
most probably very anxious to return ‘home'”.
So upon the young man checking in, he was
taken to a private office and a former police
officer working security for American Airlines
questioned him, then offered him a free ticket
home if he’d just admit he gave Vroom money
for a ticket.
In another case concerning Vroom, the individual,
one Sam Mulroy, was told his flight was canceled,
but that he’d be given a new ticket, free
of charge, if he’d just say he paid Vroom
for the original ticket.
Mulroy denied paying anything.
When the offer of a free ticket didn’t work,
American Airlines froze Mulroy’s Frequent
Flier account.
When Mulroy complained to American Airlines
and the U.S. Department of Transportation
that he felt he was being extorted by the
airline, his account was unfrozen.
In the end, Vroom did indeed lose his pass
when it was discovered in a subsequent lawsuit
that he really had accepted payment for at
least a few flights.
Vroom, however, claimed the payments were
for “business advice” (Vroom is a very
successful marketing consultant), not for
the tickets.
However, Vroom’s lawyers noted that it shouldn’t
matter whether he accepted payments or not,
as American Airlines didn’t explicitly ban
the practice of selling tickets in their “unlimited”
pass contracts until three years after Vroom
purchased his.
Other customers who lost their passes included
a retired bond broker called Willard May who’d
been very openly using his pass to ferry people
across America for a fee for about two decades
and the aforementioned Steven Rothstein for
things like booking empty seats for his suitcase
under the name “Bag Rothstein”.
While May decided against pursuing the matter
in court, Rothstein did.
He ultimately lost when a judge ruled he had
indeed violated the terms of his contract.
(Amusingly given how it all turned out, Rothstein
once met the aforementioned American Airlines
chief executive Robert Crandall during a flight,
prompting the then CEO to send Rothstein a
letter saying, “I am delighted that you’ve
enjoyed your AAirpass investment.
You can count on us to keep the company solid,
and to honor the deal, far into the future.”)
At least two others were also found to have
been in breach of their contracts, according
to American Airlines, but their tickets were
not revoked for undisclosed reasons.
For the curious, you can still purchase an
AAirpass today, though not too shockingly,
American Airlines no longer offers an unlimited
version.
The last time they did so was in 2004, three
years before they’d realised exactly how
much these passes were costing them every
year.
At that time, they offered the pass through
Neiman-Marcus for $3 million (about $3.7 million
today) per pass.
Despite that this would have still been a
pretty good deal for a certain type of wealthy
flyer or certain businesses to have such tickets
at their disposal any time, nobody bought
any at that
price point.